(applause)
Oh, no.
Hi, first of all, I'm sorry.
I just, I there's a chin resting
on the table and I, he's like half asleep.
She just decided she needed to be here right now.
So she is here.
Oh my God, Vanessa. What's her name?
It's Darla.
She's my angel.
Oh my God.
She show cute, I can't even handle it.
(laughter)
It's so nice to see you.
It's so nice to see you, I was just thinking about
back in the day, we went to a Kings of Leon
concert together.
You, me and Zach Efron.
And it was one of the funnest nights of my life.
Wait, are you kidding me? It's like still a story I tell
to this day I was like, that was such a wild time.
I remember being there and,
I was like, man, what's happening? This is so amazing.
You were so sweet.
I was so I was literally your and Zac's third wheel.
Yeah, love that for us.
(laughter)
It was so fun. and you guys were so cute and cozy
and I just had the best time and I was just like, yeah
this is why people should socialize.
Love that, love that.
Okay. Mother's day is this Sunday, and you recently
gave your mom a little make-over
and will you tell me about it?
This is so lovely.
Yeah, it's so funny.
So last year I started the year working on
Tick, Tick... Boom! in New York, and I had three weeks
off when they were in production.
So I was like, it's perfect, I told my mom, she could live
in my house cause I'm going to be away.
I'll go home, check on my mom
and then, like, get back to New York and get back to work.
Obviously, the lockdown happened and I ended
up going into quarantine with my mom.
So we spent every single day together.
We were doing each other's makeup.
She wanted to do like a Cleopatra inspired look.
And she's just hilarious. She is literally one
of the most brightest shining people that I know.
She's just adorable. She's so fun.
You know, like she's my biggest supporter, my biggest fan.
And I'm her biggest fan back.
I think we just have, like, a feeling
of mutual respect for each other.
And the older that I get, the more that I realize
I'm turning into my mother.
(laughter)
We all
It's cool, like, my mom's dope, like, I'm down.
I celebrate your guys' relationship so much
in this mother's day.
And I know your friend, Ashley Tisdale just had a baby too,
for mother's day coming up.
I know it's so crazy, I saw her yesterday
just like, you are a mom.
Like, it's just so weird.
I feel like she's her and another girlfriend ended
up having a baby on the same day and they were
always talking about having kids together and it
happened literally at the same time and I'm just like
my friends are having babies like, it's happening now.
It's just, it's wild.
(upbeat music)